and the immediate aftermath of those
mass shootings two mosques in New
Zealand the media worked overtime to try
to link President Trump to the tragedy
of course well this sick narrative
continued today with new odious charges
yes he's crazy he's a white nationalist
racially and ethnically insensitive
personal grievance that is precisely
consistent with the white nationalist
agenda this whole racial bigoted
perception of the president is an
albatross around his neck joining me now
exclusively so happy he's with us I've
been asking him to come on for a while
is Ben Carson of course the Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development
dr. Carson the only african-american in
the cabinet you can take a swing at that
I mean I heard white nationalist
repeated so many times in relation to
the president his policies those are
white nationalist his emphasis is on
white nationalism over and over again
your reaction well you know there's a
narrative that's being painted there but
you know I've had an opportunity to
interact with racist people throughout
my life and he is not one he is so easy
to be around so relaxed and treats you
at the utmost respect and you know I
talked with him early on about the
plight of many people particularly in
the inner city and the compassion that
he showed is very impressive but you
know he doesn't wear it on his sleeve
you know he believes that a rising tide
lifts all boats and he doesn't go around
playing identity politics he said let's
just fix this so that everybody does
well well one of the things that I found
most amazing that got almost no coverage
because you've gotten hammered recently
we'll get to that but you actually
worked with the Bill DeBlasio you can't
get pretty much any more of a liberal
mayor than Bill DeBlasio
but you worked with him because the New
York Housing Authority has been plagued
with all sorts of problems dilapidated
housing rodents infested this goes on
and on there was a federal takeover of
New York City Housing Authority January
31st became official I would have
thought de Blasio would have hammered
you de Blasio went on and on about
how it's it's a it's a new path forward
he said you're a very responsive you
were very responsive yeah what we've
done today creates a strong path forward
he said a tangible path forward he says
it will change and improve the lives of
public housing residents we wanted to
make sure there would be results right
what happened there are you and here
like more pals now I'll tell you what
really happened and I wish that's what
happened in our Congress too we just
decided to put the people first we said
let's whatever we talk about let's
always keep the people at the forefront
and do those things that will actually
benefit them and you know that's the
approach that we've taken in all of our
HUD projects and you know we're looking
at our react scoring we're looking at
ways to get people out of the squalor
you know a lot of people say well why do
you let people live in this dilapidated
place it's because we don't have another
place to put them since we've have
another place to put them believe me we
would do that but you know you have to
weigh all of these things very carefully
and having grown up around that I'm very
very interested in making sure that that
we give people the kind of quality life
that will allow them the freedom to
think about something other than are
they going to survive the night yeah
well rats are going up and in cities
across the United States and yet the the
left lot of fair housing activists say
well HUD is cutting programs 18%
proposed budget cut for this fiscal year
10,000 units of public housing are lost
to decay every year according to your
own department and saying that you're
not enough doing enough to address this
well there are those who believe that
just throwing money at the problem is
the only solution you know we're looking
at a lot of solutions first of all the
budget that has been proposed make sure
that we protect everybody in all of the
housing programs nobody is going to be
thrown out but we're looking at things
like the rad program rental assistance
demonstration which comes and remodels
and rebuilds a lot of these dilapidated
places and takes care of that deferred
maintenance that's been put off for so
long because the system that we had been
using just allowed it to continue to
accumulate and people to get further
and we're changing to a public-private
partnership system that's what they
don't like is that what's going on here
because I mean I have to confess I
didn't follow a lot of what HUD was
doing I'm focusing all these it but
there actually is some interview
Opportunity Zones you know obviously
that's a huge huge effort that's
currently underway it's what they got
near NBC's and current and former HUD
HUD people say well you don't have a
sense of urgency because you're very
calm unlike me would you like to have a
neurosurgeon who panics every time
exactly that's what they know you know
they're looking at things the way they
used to be we're looking at things the
way that they need to be and we're
changing things and they can't relate to
that and I you know I don't talk about
them I don't blame them they just can't
understand and they don't talk to us and
when we they did to our talk to us they
distort what's going on so I don't
really worry about them I just worry
about doing what's right and the proof
will be in the pudding and we are
working to get people out of poverty
with the opportunity zones you know
people have made a lot of money over the
last couple of years now we're providing
a mechanism where they can take their
unrealized capital gains invest them in
places that have traditionally been
neglected and give people wood in
Chicago I got a lot of new friends there
from our show that we did their angle
would Compton I mean we're going into
absolutely parts of Detroit because
they're traditionally not conservative
places but I think we would hope that
we'll see real progress our
understanding is our people our most
valuable resource and if we develop them
and make them productive we only
strengthen ourselves as a nation we only
have three hundred and thirty million
people China and India have four times
that many people will never be able to
compete with them unless we learn to
develop our people and I think we
understand that so I'm apparently just
put your feet up on your desk all day
and you sipping mai-tais heading down to
Florida on the weekends I mean you get
your schedules getting hammered these
are by the people who cover the Congress
is home every night every week at you
know Thursday afternoon you know
I look at it if that's the worst that
they can find that I go home some
weekends and that I may leave early on a
Friday in order to get there if that's
the worst that they can find as much as
they've been scrutinized and we're in
pretty good shape this job compared to
neurosurgery on children what are you
finding most frustrating and most
fulfilling well of course you know as a
surgeon I still have a surgical
personality get it done now and here you
to deal with bureaucracy and you know
bureaucrats tend to think that the rules
are much more important than the goals
so you know adjusting to that but not
adjusting to the point where you could
pitch elate to it trying to change it
you know we brought in to HUD now a CFO
we didn't have a CFO for eight and a
half years can you imagine with the
billions of dollars flowing through
there so there was really not the kind
of fiscal control that you would expect
now we have that would bring in the
kinds of controls that actually will
allow us to give more freedom to the
various jurisdictions because we can
keep track of where the money is and how
it's being used and what the timelines
are all of those things are changing
we're upgrading our IT systems we still
have a good ways to go but we're making
progress there is it the slow pace of
things and everyone I go up into Carson
talk so slowly well that we need people
to talk more slowly if they're making
sense in my view but that's that's that
that I would imagine that's frustrating
for you this is a little pace of change
it's for the president as well are you
gonna stick around for a while you're
gonna be in the cabinet for a while
I plan on it you know there was the
hoopla a couple of weeks ago Carson's
leaving you know I was asked what am I
going to do and I said you know my
preference is to go back into the
private sector
it was extremely enjoyable and you had a
great deal of freedom and you had a lot
of influence because I was you know
speaking out a lot more at that time but
you know what we're doing is also
incredibly important does that mean
you're gonna stay a thread for the next
year it means that I oh I will
definitely finish out the first term and
I'm open to a second term
secretary Carson do not be a stranger we
need to see more of it we get a lot of a
lot of requests to have you on the show
absolutely don't be a stranger we'll
have to have as Arnold say I'll be back
all right